-Guys, do you ever see
a photo in the news
and think the headline
should be different?
Well, we'll take of that
right now.
It's time for
"News & Improved."
Here we go.
-♪ "News & Improved" ♪
-Whoo!
For example, check out
this first photo here.
The original headline was...
Alright. The headline
can definitely be improved,
'cause if you only
looked at the photo,
the headline could've been...
[ Laughter, applause ]
Up next, the headline says...
The headline could've been...
They're like, "Uh..."
[ Applause ]
Next headline was...
Headline could've been...
[ Laughter, applause ]
-Oh!
So bad!
[ Laughs ]
-The next headline was...
Headline could've been...
-Oh, my God.
-They look different, yeah.
This next headlines was...
Headline could've been...
[ Laughter, applause ]
♪♪
Next headline was...
The headline could've been...
[ Laughter, applause ]
"I love you, man."
Next headline was...
Headline could've been...
It's like...
Oh. Ooh.
Finally, this headline was...
But the headline
could've been...
Like, "Oh!"
That's all the time we have
for "News & Improved"!